à moins de trois semaines des élections
les partisans du premier ministre viktor
orban n'ont répondu en grand nombre à
son appel à la mobilisation en ce jour
de fête nationale ils sont venus d'un
peu partout en hongrie lui réitéré leur
appui
ces jeunes espèrent une victoire du
fides la formation de viktor orban
malgré l'inflation ses partisans vantent
notamment sa gestion de l'économie
hongroise au cours des 12 dernières
années
le pays n'a jamais été en aussi bonne
santé ajoute cet homme mais pour ses
adversaires après trois mandats
consécutifs de viktor orban dont le pays
est en pleine dérive autoritaire
l'opposition tente le tout pour le tout
pour le défaire cette année six parties
se sont unies derrière peter marquise
haye le maire conservateur d'une petite
ville du pays
une alliance aussi inusité
qu'incontournable selon cet élu
écologiste de budapest qui déplorent les
impacts de la transformation de la
hongrie depuis plus d'une décennie les
jeunes s'en vont les forces vives
commandiez de la nation sans sur le
départ donc si on
la remporte pas cette fois ci c'est pas
ce qui va rester de ce pays depuis des
années les adversaires de viktor orban
lui reproche de s'attaquer à
l'indépendance de la justice et des
médias et de porter atteinte aux droits
des minorités au cours des dernières
semaines c'est surtout sa relation avec
la dîmière poutine qui a alimenté les
attaques de l'opposition
nous devons choisir l'europe plutôt
clair a lancé le candidat de
l'opposition une attaque à peine voilée
à l'endroit de viktor orban qui a fait
de moscou un allié central de la
politique étrangère hongroise tant sur
le plan énergétique que stratégique on
peut dire que son meilleur ami c'est
vladimir poutine parce qu'ils ont eu des
rencontres annuelles chaque année et se
sont rencontrés jusqu'à la pandémie
depuis le début de la guerre dans
l'ukraine voisine le premier ministre
hongrois à ajuster certaines de ses
positions généralement hostiles à
l'émigration viktor orban n'a permis
l'accueil de centaines de milliers de
réfugiés sur son territoire
régulièrement confié avec bruxelles il a
même approuvé les sanctions de l'union
européenne contre la russie un
revirement somme toute limitée constate
cet ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères il a soutenu les décisions de
l'union européenne les sanctions contre
la russie mais en même temps il a fait
des déclarations en faveur de la russie
il a monté une certain compréhension
pour les revendications de deux du
gouvernement russe monsieur poutine
devant ses partisans viktor orban ne
répète qu'il refuse toute implication
militaire dans le conflit il s'est aussi
opposé à ce que des armes transitent par
la hongrie
sa stratégie se présenter en défenseur
de la paix dans un pays qui a lui-même
une histoire trouble avec moscou rien
d'étonnant pour ses électeurs
indépendants
selon lui viktor orban est prête à tout
pour gagner cette élection dans ce pays
marqué plus que jamais par d'importantes
divisions il cira fait le bouvier
auclair radio-canada à budapest